well i think what joey was arguing was
that she was never
in blackface because she intended her
blackface
halloween costume to be an homage
to black women that's what she said it
was an homage
and you know it's funny because i i
remember people saying very clearly when
i tried to discuss this issue about
whether there could ever be an instance
where you were trying to
honor someone um where it might be
acceptable
and all hell broke loose
this is where you know for someone like
me that used to be
a left you know i was a lefty i was a
democrat the whole thing
where it's like every message that now
pretty much comes out
of the left is this is a racist nation
this is racism racism racism
and then the average person if you cite
any of those studies or if you read any
book by thomas soule or listen to any
talk by larry elder
they'll somehow tell you that you know
well they'll actually call those guys
sellouts or uncle toms or something else
but then even the fact that you've cited
them they'll use as proof of your racism
because you found a black person that
agrees with you and it's almost like
there's just nothing left to talk about
it's it's very depressing actually i
mean i think for you know
me and you like i don't really care like
it's fine you can call me whatever you
want to call me i'm going to say what's
true
i am going to say the facts and if you
don't like the facts
you don't have to listen to me great you
can go you want to write write up what i
said good bad or ugly go for it that's
just more exposure of my world view
but you don't have to listen um
i i think it's more problematic for you
know
the civilians if you will right people
who don't
engage in punditry uh for a living
because they're scared
they've genuine and i i would say like
the most disturbing part about
the end of my time at nbc was
the message it sent to you know the
folks on the street which is
you say one quote wrong thing
you're dead you know you're dead and
that is just not the country most of us
want to live in
you know i it really upsets me when i
see what's happening with teenagers
you know like these teenagers who are
getting their lives ruined
because they say and do stupid stuff
just like we all said and did
stupid stuff uh and now no more in
today's day and age
you're done yeah so i don't want to
rehash all the
all the past stuff in nbc and all that
but i did see uh recently when
when kim klasik who's running for uh
representative for i think it's district
seven in baltimore
she was on the view she got into it with
the ladies and
a little bit of a cat fight started and
she basically said well joy
talking to joy behar you know you've
been in blackface and you had a pretty
clever
tweet about the sort of double standard
on this stuff that sort of if you're a
lefty liberal
you can kind of get away with not only
being in blackface but also pretending
that the whole black community as joy
said sort of supports her
where it was a little different for you
well well i think what joey was arguing
was that she was never
in blackface because she intended her
blackface
halloween costume to be an homage
to black women that's what she said it
was an homage
and you know it's funny because i i
remember people saying very clearly when
i tried to discuss this issue about
whether there could ever be an instance
where you were trying to
honor someone um where it might be
acceptable
and though all hell broke loose and so i
was waiting i was waiting to see you she
works for abc i was waiting to see
a report on um world news tonight right
uh like like they did with me
on gma like they did with me um on nbc
nbc was totally interested in my
comments but i didn't see lester holt
covered joy behar's comments
and yet the whole world gave a very
strong message that you may never
you homage no intent is not
relevant it's not and even just last
week chris rock was saying intent is
relevant
in talking about why he forgave jimmy
kimmel or jimmy fallon
for um playing him with black face on
so anyway i of course there's a double
standard you know it's like
you got to live with it you can't just
like boo-hoo but it's kind of fun to
call attention to it because
they just can't get out of it you know
what i mean the left is like the media
is so dishonest and i really make no
distinction between the left and the
media they're
other than fox and sort of declared
conservative media
there are no conservative uh outlets or
even center or independent outlets
they're all left so that's actually kind
of where i wanted to go next
so what do you make of just generally
like the state of journalism well first
off do you consider
cable pundits and all of the faces and
even
you know what i do and the other people
that are doing this on youtube and
everywhere else
like do you consider all of us
journalists like i don't consider myself
a journalist i'm telling people what i
think i'm interviewing people
but i'm not out in the field you know
collecting information and reporting on
it i can
i can read a story and and process it
and tell people what i think
but but i think a lot of people think
that don lemon is a journalist like i
don't consider him
or chris cuomo a journalist or even
tucker i don't consider
a journalist do you think that even
matters like
what we're calling them i think it
matters i think there's still a
distinction between journalists and
pundits
and uh you know opinion journalists
that's another sort of category
um i think the problem with somebody
like lemon or cuomo is they don't
they're not honest about it they
actually think they're straight news
journalists
so i'm told is rachel maddow she thinks
she's a straight news journalist
and i've got no beef with rachel maddow
it's fine she can say what she wants
every night but let's not pretend
it it's a fact that it's
journalistically sound it's not and you
need to look no further than her
coverage of russiagate
for proof of that um yeah i think it's
amazing that they'll put those guys
on cnn out there at a presidential
debate as moderators trying to pawn them
off to the audience
as straight news guys you know that
they're they are not
straight news journalists they're not
and even like fox would never use tucker
for a presidential debate
but tucker he is a journalist he's got a
background in journalism but he's
morphed over to the opinion side right
but his
his background is in journalism i think
he's more over to the opinion side and
he doesn't make any
you know secret of that fox news would
never have sean hannity
sitting there anchoring a presidential
debate or at least they wouldn't have
when i was there
because they understood you got the
journalists you know like paris faulkner
and brett bear who do journalism
journalism and then you got the
appendage
journalism and then you got the opinion
folks who who are great at what they do
yeah do you think journalism can come
back i mean
you probably see me do it on twitter all
the time but every time i have to write
the word journalist or journalism i have
to put air quotes around it because it
seems
just so absolutely far gone
i don't have a lot of hopes for it i
gotta be honest i
i don't know that it can i think you
know more and more we're moving into
this
land where there's no demilitari let me
try to say that again
there's no demilitarized zone you know
it's like
people are they're forcing you to pick a
side and um
i don't think that i'm not sure people
really even
want you know crazy sort of uncle walter
he wasn't crazy but you know what i mean
like sort of let me tell you the news
anymore i think they kind of want spin
they want a little bit of their
world view reflected and i actually
think that that's
that's why some of the fox news
journalists do so well like if you watch
brett bear's program
he understands who his audience is it is
not a newscast
that reflects what you read in the new
york times right this is what i used to
do on the kelly file
um so you understand who you're
programming to
right but then you discuss the news in a
way that's truly fair and balanced
so it's not diminishing or dismissive
of either side the way it always is if
you see
anything discussed especially cultural
issues on these other channels
like when was the last time you heard
msnbc discuss homeschooling
uh in any way other than with disgust or
the second amendment or religion in the
public square
you know they they're disgusted by
people who believe in those things and
it shows
so anyway i don't have high opportunity
i see us getting more and more partisan
and retreating to those corners
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell